- We have so many little legal
battles that we have to fight
on an ongoing basis that
people never hear about.
The issue becomes when
you can no longer actually
do your work or
run your business.
And with Facebook, this has
been going on for a long time
a lot of back and forth.
And then the biggest
independent election stream ever
in this election
that we were doing
at 15 million people watching.
That's not including
whatever numbers on Facebook
that vanished, was removed.
And by the way, it's
still up on YouTube.
There isn't even a
soft copyright claim
and Facebook never
gave us any reason.
(upbeat music)
- I'm Dave Rubin
and joining me today
is a comedian, a podcaster
and host of Louder with
Crowder on BlazeTV,
Steven Crowder, welcome
back to the Rubin Report
for the first time,
since April of 2016.
- April, 2016, while
I've had you on my show
way more times than that.
(laughs)
So some equitable.
- I've been on your
show dozens of times,
but somehow, literally, I mean
this is almost five years, man.
- Well, I think you
always wanted me to do it.
You always wanted to have
people physically in studio
and now with the COVID
you'll take what you can get.
And so thanks for
having me, Dave.
- Yeah, it is good to have you.
You are doing a first
here on the Rubin Report.
I have never had a
guest on the show before
who requested to come on
the show with their lawyer.
And if I'm not mistaken
that is your Asian lawyer
sitting right next to
you Bill Richardson.
Why did you bring your lawyer?
- Hold on second,
first he's half-Asian
and Bill Richmond is the
Governor of New Mexico.
This is a half Asian Bill
Richmond, but close enough.
- Oh, Bill Richmond did
I think Bill Richardson?
- Yeah, and actually there a
little bit of a resemblance.
- So there is a little bit of
a resemblance one for sure.
- There is the
shape of the head.
- I mean, sometimes my
wife even mistakes me
and calls me Bill Richardson
if I had a little bit too
much booze so I get it.
(laughs)
- No, I just had him on,
well he's on he's on
the show quite a bit.
And so it's different from
having, a lawyer on just saying,
"Don't say that,
can't say that."
Since he often
acts like a co-host
and also to make sure
that I don't screw up
since what we're
talking about is.
We've talked about this,
a lot of conservatives
out there, sort of.
There's a little bit of
sometimes crying Wolf.
For a post was removed.
and so I'm gonna go
to war with Facebook.
But since it's an
actual suit filed
that could prove to be
a landmark situation.
He makes sure that,
I don't just fly by
the seat of my pants.
- Okay, well half-Asian
Bill Richmond
it's good to have you here.
And you know what
Crowder I was gonna do
some personal stuff with
you but let's shove it.
Let's just dive
right into this thing
because the big tech
censorship thing,
I mean this is the
issue of the day.
It's like, it's not a
issue, it is the issue
because it's our only way to
communicate at least right now.
And you're not
happy with YouTube.
You're not thrilled with Twitter
but you're really not
happy with Facebook?
- You know, what's funny
is actually probably
obviously the people
with whom I would have
the most grievances
would be YouTube.
Sorry guys about
the Vox Adpocalypse
I didn't intend for that.
- Thanks for that, by the way.
- Yeah, I know, you
know, I'm guilty.
But Facebook has been
going on for a long time
and here's the thing.
I just wanna do my show,
I just want to do my work.
Bill knows us, he's been on
retainer for a long time.
We have so many little legal
battles that we have to fight
on an ongoing basis that
people never hear about.
The issue becomes when
you can no longer actually
do your work or
run your business.
And with Facebook, this has
been going on for a long time
a lot of back and forth.
And then the biggest
independent election stream ever
in this election
that we were doing
15 million people watching.
That's not including
whatever numbers on Facebook
that vanished, was removed.
And by the way, it's
still up on YouTube.
There isn't even a
soft copyright claim
and Facebook never
gave us any reason.
And then after that sort
of throttling the page
saying that this page can
only be viewed by your fans
and never gave us
any reason in this.
And this is a long time coming
because to give you an
idea, this dates back to,
I've been doing this
for a long time.
And when people talk
about folks out there
who do this for their money
you can go back in 2009 where
I was doing videos on YouTube
with a blue bedsheet,
there was no money.
There were no
conservatives online.
It was really just sort of me
out in the middle of the desert.
And I was very unlikeable,
very punchable face
rightfully Sir Jason
priestly sideburns
people can go back and see it.
But Facebook early on, I always
they approached me about
advertising on Facebook.
And so we always spend
a little bit of money
to run Ads on Facebook early on
to kinda grow the page
and we established a
business relationship.
And then at one point, for
some reason out of the blue
they said that I was,
I hadn't paid Facebook
for two weeks worth of Ads that
I was delinquent on payment.
But here's the thing.
They continued
accepting money for Ads
every week thereafter.
So they accepted money
for ads all the way up
until this two week period,
said I didn't pay it.
And then still had the same
method of payment, the same card
and bank account on file
and took money after that.
And so this is actually where
half-Asian Bill comes in.
Then there was this article
that came out on m- gadget
about this was a Facebook
- Gizmodo.
- Gizmodo, I always forget
I got them Gizmodo the verge
and gadget, whatever,
another site.
- Yeah, its all the same.
- Where they claim to be
tech sites but they write,
about how men can have
periods too, one of those.
So it was talking about how
pages we're being throttled
by Facebook and they had
this sort of screen grabs
from behind the scenes
and included Ted Cruz
for President Chris Kyle
foundation, Breitbart.
And yours truly.
And I thought, I wonder if
this relates to something
going on behind the scenes
with the payment issue.
Well, here's the thing,
I sent her a patient
fill my chats, your customer
service chats with Facebook,
not only what they saying that
my account could be removed
and my payment actually, so
I could be in delinquency
they potentially send
this to creditors.
But what had happened was I
sent a physical check finally
payable to Facebook in
wherever it is Palo Alto.
One of those places,
they deposited it.
I had the receipt of
them depositing the check
and they were going to
remove my page that week
and potentially send this to
creditors and still claiming
that I hadn't made the payment,
the only way to
remedy the situation.
And it just happened to
coincide Gizmodo gadget.
- Gizmodo.
- Gizmodo was,
to have my lawyer
reach out to them.
There was no other way
I didn't want to do it.
I sent a check by snail
mail, which they deposited
and they still were
gonna try and pipe me.
So that's how we met.
- So before we get too into
the weeds on all of the li
no there's a lot of
interesting stuff here.
And I've been saying, and we've
talked about it many times
that you have to fight the
big tech front in many ways,
you have to fight it with,
by building tech you have
to fight it by, legal means
whatever way you can fight it.
I think you have to fight it.
But Bill, when you get
the call from Crowder
and he is like all right,
let's do this with Facebook,
with any of these
other companies.
I think a lot of lawyers
would be like, no,
I just don't wanna
deal with the headache.
I don't wanna deal with the
massive amounts of lawyers
that they have, the
millions and millions
and it's not even
millions and millions.
It just the endless
amount of money
that they have to fight me.
- That a little bit.
I mean, Zuckerberg,
hasn't seen a million
in probably a decade and a half.
You're talking about
many, many billions.
- Yeah, exactly.
So what is it about about you
that makes you wanna
work with a guy like this
and get into the
fight, go crazy.
- Yeah, it's a combination
of one being crazy
but also being convicted
of the values that go into
when businesses need
to treat people right.
So when Steven and I first met
we had never had a
conversation before.
We'd never talked about
anything on any point whatsoever
a mutual connection
brought us together.
They had tried to reach
out to other lawyers
about trynna get this
to happen back in 2016
when this originally occurred.
- And I'm pretty sure you
thought it was foolish yeah.
- I definitely thought
it was spam or craziness
or, you get a lot of calls as
a lawyer about certain cases.
And you're just not sure about
whether there are any good
but when you started to
put together these facts
it was at first, Hey, I wonder
what's going on with this check.
And then when the
Gizmodo article hit,
you really realized that
this is something much larger
than just a accounting
snafu or a company deciding
that they don't particularly
like a certain creator.
It becomes much more
nefarious than that.
To the point of, even with
regards to that Gizmodo article
there were Senate
investigations and other thing
and this is back in 2016.
Well, for everything
that we're hearing
in the last couple of years,
and especially the
last couple of months
regarding section 230
and really the new rally
and war path that Facebook
has been on against creators.
- Bill, what would you say
to the people that would say,
Hey they're private companies.
They can do whatever they want.
They can work with
whoever they want.
If they wanna cut you off,
if they wanna shut you down
they have every right to do it.
- I say, you're right.
And they're still wrong
because we're pro-business
but anti-fraud,
America has been built
on having companies
and people individually, you
can contract with someone
and you can say, "Hey, we're
gonna do certain things,
"where I'm gonna
operate cleanly."
You have statutes in almost
every state that protects
against anti-competitive
behavior
and unfair and deceptive
trade practices.
And what you have from
Facebook is exactly that
because what
they're trying to do
and what they have
been doing is saying,
"Hey go create for
us, create content."
We don't know how
to create content
but we need you to
create that content
bring your people,
bring your followers.
And with them comes the
most valuable thing.
It's not really the
eyeballs and ears.
Those are a by-product,
it's the data.
It's the data points
that they can use to
sell the advertising.
Everyone knows that,
you know when you sign
on for the free product,
you're the product.
But in this part, that's
where the fraud is
because they're saying
that we have a platform
where we're uniformly
and nondiscriminatorily
and without political
bias enforce our policies.
They even said that back in 2016
in defense to the Senate letter
they said, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no,
we never engage in political
viewpoint discrimination
despite what this
whistleblower employee has said
despite what our
written handbook says
about these particular names.
And they sit in
front of Congress as
recently as last year
saying, no, no, no, no, no,
we do not engage in that.
But when you look at the
actual pattern and practice
of who's getting shut down,
who's getting throttled
despite the popularity
of that content,
despite the fact that we
have a country who's craving
certain values and viewpoints,
even if they disagree
to at least hear them
and disagree with them
you know that that's
what's happening.
This isn't about saying,
"Oh, I don't want to
"I don't want you as a
business owner to control
"who comes into your business
or who uses your platform."
It's about saying that
if you promise a product
that says it's going to be open
that it's gonna be enforced
in a certain way and you
publish those policies
you just have to stick by them.
- Yeah.
- Yeah and so...
go ahead.
- I would say, I think
something too is,
Bill was always known
that I've approached this
as a business owner.
When people see me complaining
about something publicly,
we do a D platform this
campaign or something like
that's because the fight
is coming to my doorstep.
I want to be able to run my
program and run my business.
And we even said, look if
you have different rules
from what we've been told,
tell us what they are.
Now, that's one thing that
happened at least at that time
of the Vox Adpocalypse,
where they said,
okay these videos
need to be removed.
You need to change your shirt
your mustache was different.
They added guidelines
again, sorry
because I hadn't violated any.
But then I said, okay, your
sandbox, your rules understood.
With Facebook, they
still haven't given any
there's no answer,
no reply, no reason
for removing the
biggest election stream
that's ever taken place
in an online platform.
By the way more
people were watching
and I don't say this to brag.
We've talked about
this for a long time.
A lot of people go out there
and try and tout their numbers.
I want the content
to speak for itself.
More people were watching
us than Brian Williams
and CNN combined, and Facebook
gave no reason to this day,
zero justification for it.
At a certain point, you have
to know what the rules are.
Didn't they just say
it wasn't Friday.
- Yeah.
- Now they just
totally demonetized the
page, which is fine.
We said what was
the reason listed?
- None,.
- None whatsoever.
I've invested over
the year since 2009
that we're talking about
millions of dollars
into growing a business.
I mean, if you build a
building for whatever,
it's a coffee shop,
a pizza parlor.
And then someone comes
in and says, by the way
we're taking back
the foundation.
No, I paid for that
and we agreed to that.
And if you change the
rules, well first off
there's some legality there.
And then tell me what
the new rules are.
Do I need to pay for
updates to finish?
What do you have to
corner of the building?
They haven't given
us any answers.
So this is the only option
available to me, not the first.
- What would you guys say to
all of the media matters people
and the Vox people and
the daily beast people
who no doubt will
be watching this.
And they will say,
but wait a minute
Crowder under half Asian lawyer.
When we look at the top
10 drivers of traffic
to Facebook pages
usually four out of 10
have something to
do with Ben Shapiro.
Three of them are the blaze.
And then there's
one lefty thing.
How could that then
be the censorship
of conservative voices?
- That's actually, that's in
spite of Facebook's policy.
Now we don't know
because we don't have access
to the information algorithms
which are kept more secret
than the Coke formula
or was it the 52 herbs and
spices to the Colonel's chicken.
But I will say this, people
used to use this argument
a lot about Michael Phelps.
They would say, "Well he
eats three big Macs every day
"and he used to eat
a bunch of McDonald's
"and this kind of stuff."
And people say, "Therefore
that must be the diet
"of champions."
No, he has the wingspan
of an albatross
and a size 19 triple wide shoe.
And so he can get away
with eating McDonald's
and still being the best
swimmer in the world
because of God given
athletic capabilities.
I would say as it relates
to conservative content.
Listen the left has had all
of Maine, ABC, NBC, CBS, CNN,
MSNBC, Fox news real
up until recently
being the only one New
York times, Washington
everything, right?
The places you just
mentioned, Daily Beast, Vox
and these places are all owned
by multi-national
media conglomerates.
Like we've been in tussles
with Disney, NBC, is it then?
Or is it Disney ABC,
NBC universal Turner.
- Viacom.
- Viacom, all of them
never lost any of them.
And so I think that a
lot of people go online
for the same reason this show
has been as successful as it.
For something that is an
alternative point of view
alternative to what?
Everything else.
And so the fact that
people are craving truth
and information that
they cannot find anywhere
on their television dial
that conservatives shouldn't
be faulted for that.
It's just that the left listen
they've had every other platform
and they're not
nearly as competitive
here on Facebook right now.
So just, just because
they're more successful
it doesn't mean that that's
because Facebook's
favoring them.
- So to jump off of
that day real quick
is really what it
comes down to is that
the in spite of
argument is very true.
It's not about how much
is actually being shown.
It's much would have
otherwise been shown
if you had enforced
your policies correctly.
And if at the end, Facebook's
one of their arguments.
One of their defenses might
be our platform sucks.
People don't like it.
That's why we're not
getting that much views.
That's why the streams
aren't doing as well.
Our software just broke down.
We have no reason.
Like it's just, we're actually
really bad at what we do.
That might be one
of their defenses.
So, but ultimately it's
about what should have been
not about what they've
actually providing.
Despite the fact that there are
numerous conservative
platforms and voices
that are getting good
traction despite the policies.
It's nonetheless doesn't
speak to the second point
which is the individual
question about certain voices.
There are certain voices that
have gotten more attention
in a bad way from
the powers that be
whether it's YouTube,
Twitter, or Facebook.
And Steven is one of those.
When you looked back at
the 2016 Gizmodo article
that example, there was based
on only having four names
of all the conservative
voices out there at the time
you had Rush, you had
Daily Wire, you had Shapiro
you had all these other
names that were out there.
You were out there.
One of the names
that was out there
maybe not fully in
the conservative
sphere at that point
but when you have
all those names
and only a few were targeted
you have to ask the
question of why.
And so our lawsuit is not about
saying that there's this
widespread top to bottom.
Every single person
is they're saying
they hate conservatives.
What it's about is saying,
if you can bend the rules
without giving full
business disclosure.
If you can commit fraud
that is anti-competitive
one media company complaining
to another media company
to shut down a
third media company.
If all of that is legal, then
you don't have laws anymore.
You don't have an
equal playing field
that the law guarantees.
We're not saying that we
wanna change the rules.
We're saying enforce the
rules as you have stated them.
And if not be honest about
what the real rules are.
Tell us what you're doing.
Tell us how you're enforcing it.
Don't wait until it's
a Senating inquiry
or a Facebook whistleblower.
Though I will tell you,
people are coming
out of the woodwork
to talk about what's going on
and it's only getting worse.
- Yeah, Crowder as a guy
that's been doing this forever.
Don't you kind of
admire the elegance
of their evil in a certain way?
Like I have no doubt
that you see the same
things that I see.
Like there are certain weeks
when they let my videos be seen.
Like you're out there we're
getting the normal numbers
or Twitter, suddenly I can
get thousands of retweets
on everything and then
there's suddenly a week
where I'm purging followers
and I get five
retweets on something.
Like that sort of
elegance by design
of just keeping us all
on our toes constantly
so that we can't be like,
"Oh, there's the smoking gun"
Because every freaking week
something else happens.
- Yeah, no game has
to respect game.
And when you look at
me, like, I'm okay.
Kind of like right now
with the merit Garland
like remember me, I'm like,
ah, that's one for you.
(laughs)
Okay, all right fair play.
No, you're absolutely right.
I mean, listen, the reason
that we haven't been hurt
on YouTube, for
example, with traffic.
So this is separate
from Facebook
is because we know that
you can be beholden
to algorithms, to search,
to browse, to suggest it.
And so we plug every time we
do a show, look just tune in
Monday through 10:00 AM,
Eastern, we've set a schedule.
That's not something
that's really typical
of online content doing
it live at a set time.
A good portion of our
traffic comes from people
just bookmarking the page
so that we aren't in Matt
Drudge before he went
who Matt Drudge today.
And he said, don't be beholden
to these social media ghettos.
Now that doesn't mean
that everybody else has had to
come up with contingency plan
over contingency plan
for their business model.
But we have, we've
always had to try
and look around those corners.
So the fact that we
have, for example
the fact that we have,
millions of people tuning
into these shows on YouTube.
That's not necessarily
because we're showing up
in browser suggested
all the time.
It's because we have
planned for this scenario
where we are never suggested.
And so we've had
to act accordingly
and listen that makes
us more competitive.
And I think that conservatives
in general are
pretty industrious.
I don't know about the top 10
but I can tell you what traffic
we were getting at
Facebook once upon a time
versus now I can tell you
how often we were trending
versus now I can only tell
you about my experience.
And then I'd like to
compare notes with Facebook
but they don't answer
at all ever period.
- Yeah, it's like, well, Google.
I mean, if you
were to forget us.
Like forget us, the guys
that do this for a living.
But if the average
person had a problem
with their Gmail account,
who are you gonna call?
Like there's no phone number.
- I'm sure what Jet Ski
we'll get right on that.
(laughing)
- Yeah, she'll be all over it.
Does any of this just seem
like the obvious end game
of where all of the kind
of social justice lunacy
that you and I
have been screaming
about for years was gonna go.
In other words,
that these companies
have chosen the social
justice ideology.
They've chosen the equity
ideology they've chosen to have,
their board have a
certain amount of trans
people and gay people,
and guys like you and I,
we rail against this stuff.
So it's like, this
shouldn't surprise us.
That they would try to go
after someone like you.
- No it doesn't surprise me.
I've always sort of had
a target on my back.
That doesn't surprise me.
It would does surprise me.
Is the flagrant disregard
for like Bill was laying out
just basic honest
business practices.
You know what I mean?
If you change the
rules, let us know.
I don't think we
violated any rules
with the election stream.
I mean...
- So, Bill, what if
they're just like, okay,
so like the lawsuit
moves forward,
there's a little bit of
discovery and they're like,
"Oh yeah it turns out,
some random engineer
"did actually click a switch,
"but we're not gonna
do that anymore."
Is that enough for you guys?
Like what's the
goal of the loss?
- And a random guy
at accounts payable
and a random guy at legal
counsel who doesn't and...
- There's a lot of
random guys over there?
- That's a thing it
would have to be,
30 different strange
coincidence is all the way
across many years and across
many different departments
you would have to have
just literally had
every single person
screw up continuously,
which is why I said again
one of their ultimate
defenses might just be,
we're really, really bad
at everything that we do
which would completely be
against everything they say
in their quarterly
stockholder statement.
So, when you're talking
to your shareholders
and you're telling about
what your company is
and how you do it,
we're all we're asking for
these types of disclosures.
And really when it
comes down to the relief
the first thing is stop
doing what you're doing.
Stop saying that
your policies are A
and then actually enforcing B.
And if they say, well,
we're not doing that.
We point all the way back
to 2016 of the pattern.
And here's one of the things
that's really interesting.
It's not something that
is different from what they
have done in other ways,
they've done it
with app creators
where they've said,
come and join us,
come and look at our platform.
Come make these things, create
your games, create your apps.
Now people are gonna be
very, very excited about it.
And we'll give you
all of this data.
Then all of a sudden they
decide cut the data stream
charge more, make you buy ads.
Again, all of that
is what it comes
down to is a bait and switch.
If you've got a platform
and you've got a business
just be open about it.
But if your business
model is premised
on tricking creators into
putting content on your system
to get their followers to come
and then you shuttle
those followers to the ads
using the data that you got
from them under a false premise
consumers and creators
are all being.
- And I will say this look,
one thing that I'll stand by as
I'm not the most
talented guy in the world
but everyone kinda knows
that I have a reputation
in this industry of
being a Clydesdale
more than a show horse,
I really do work really hard.
And I've always tried to stay
on top of understanding
how these platforms work.
And I've really had to learn
how these algorithms work.
And when it's based
on performances,
look there's a reason that
these people approached me
and assigned a one-to-one
person to manage the accounts
and say, "Hey, we'd like
you to run these ads"
when YouTube, sorry
when Facebook launched,
this is a funny story.
You tell me if I'm saying
anything that I can't say
Facebook launch show
pages for a while.
Where I was like show pages.
'Cause they wanted people to be
they wanted 'cause they wanted
to compete with YouTube.
And you remember
this, a lot of people
out there outside of the
industry, don't know this.
If you post a YouTube link
and Facebook doesn't get seen.
It really has to bust through
because that's
competitive to Facebook.
They have their video player.
We were there, we saw
when that changed.
So at one point they
were creating show pages
where they were saying, okay
which video content
is doing really well
where we just sort
of want to draft in
and claim success for the
successful video endeavors.
And they wanted to
then put these videos.
I wanted to format Facebook
so that these show pages
would show up in timelines,
kind of get it favourability.
well, they reached
out to me directly
and we had several
conversations.
We were like, well, look, we see
look at the numbers
are impressive.
And we're were like, how your?
And then the second they
watched the content.
They said, "Oh yeah,
no, you're not eligible
for a show page."
So when it was just
based on numbers on paper
they wanted me to
do a show page,
same thing with, with
YouTube advertising
where they've come in they've
set up account manager to say,
"Hey, we want to come in and
show you how to advertise."
And you know, what
could you teach us?
Because we don't know how
you're getting these kinds of
interaction rates,
literally interaction rates.
And I just say,
"You know what it is
"it's content that
people want to see.
"There's no trick, I don't have
any tricks to advertising."
"It's just getting it
in front of people."
Look when content like this
and a lot of conservative
content I would imagine
gets in front of
people, it wins.
We have an interaction
rate on Google
to give you an idea where
when you can skip an ad
on YouTube, before a video
all we ever did was just run
my videos as pre-roll ads
no advertising and have
interaction rate of over 50%,
meaning 50% didn't click,
skip ad that blew my mind.
I click skip ad.
Even if it's a movie
trailer for a film
I want to watch just out of
muscle memory or principle.
I still don't know the answer.
And they go, can you tell
us what you're doing?
Because they'd never seen it.
That shows you the
power of the ideas.
And when I were, when
a lot of credit show
has just been a number
on a piece of paper
or on their computer, no one
really uses paper anymore.
Maybe they do, I have no idea.
It seems like they
like killing trees,
but they say, "Okay
let's look at the pages
"that are doing the best so
that we can claim success
"for this endeavor
with our new show page
"or with our advertising
sort of targeting."
They've always reached out to me
when they find out what I'm
about, lying goes quite.
- This, Dave is actually
not just limited to Steven.
I mean, any page, maybe
folks who aren't as big
as a Dave Rubin have,
they're doing a personally
they're getting the email
from the ad account folks
and the show page
folks that are saying,
"Hey, come create more content.
"Hey, spend some money on ads.
"This is how the
ads are gonna work.
"This is how you're
going to reach people.
"If you do these things,
you're going to get it."
And all we're saying
is that you're putting
that Facebook is putting
a thumb on the scale
but not telling you that the
thumb is there right back.
That's what it was in 2016.
That's what it's been
in 2018, '19 and '20.
And that's what
we're seeing today.
- So Bill, you hit
something before that
I think might be the
answer here that I'm sure
you're working on, which is that
if you could just get the
shareholders or the board
but I guess the shareholders
more to see this stuff
and go, Whoa, actually
our shares are worth less
because we're discriminating
against or suppressing
whatever you want to call it.
Guys like Crowder.
And that hurts our bottom line.
'Cause those are clicks
with ad dollars associated
that it's almost like
you need the shareholders
to turn on the company.
Is that part of the strategy?
- Certainly something
that's important.
It's not part of
our direct strategy
but it's one where
the more eyeballs
and ears that are seeing what's
going on behind the scenes
anyone who has an
interest in Facebook
is gonna go why are you limiting
this particular content?
But one of the reasons that
might be a financial reason
is because of the fact that
there are so many media
companies that are
these ad buyers.
They're the ones that are
actually paying Facebook
and generating all the revenues.
Where are those companies base?
Where are your NBC
Universal's base?
Where are your Viacom's based?
Where are your Disney's based
and who are the type of
people making decisions there.
And that gets back to a
point that you made about
whether or not the wokeness
lunacy that's going on
and all of the different
social justice warrior issues.
If that's the pressure,
it is highly ironic
that companies that often
rail against capitalism
will use capitalism to
force other companies
to hurt smaller companies.
That's really what's
happening here.
And that's the media company
telling another media company
hurt another media company
because we don't like them.
- I think it was.
And it's never like bill has
said, it's never been a plan.
This strategy, it sort of
was accidental with the Vox
at apocalypse though.
Remember we found out
afterwards were like,
why aren't they
reaching out to us?
It turns out that
alphabet took a nosedive,
their stock after
the Vox at pocalypse,
because a lot of
people were upset.
And, sometimes the
market puts people
between a rock and a hard
place where it's okay.
Either appease the people
who work in your palate
in your Northern California
offices or his off
half of the most
powerful nation on earth.
And that's where they
often find themselves.
- Crowder when that ad
apocalypse thing happened.
And it had a lot to do with,
you got into a little skirmish
with this Carlos
Mazza guy from Vox
who happened to be the same guy
who lobbied Pete Booty judge
to not do my show and,
runs around calling
everyone white supremacists
and the rest of it.
Does that asymmetry
drive you nuts.
They can say whatever they
want about us all the time.
We know that and they
can do whatever damage
they want to our businesses.
But then, and I
correct me if I'm wrong
but I'm pretty sure he's
like a privileged partner
or whatever, they
call it on YouTube,
while he can say whatever
he wants about us.
But if we were to do
the same with them,
you lost your ad read for
more a year on YouTube?
- More than a year.
I don't know
exactly what it was.
I will tell you this
though, to be fair.
I never really
focused on that guy,
and I hate to correct you
but really this was just
one of or several videos in a
series of criticisms of Vox.
Vox would do their
explained series.
So we criticized
Vox all the time
just like we do with
John Oliver, just
like we do with Vice
just like it would do a slate.
And this was really
kind of edited context
what it was for me.
My problem there was
a NBC universal Vox
one of the most powerful
companies in the world
who also happen to have
a lot of advertising
dollars that they spend
with a company like YouTube,
trying to get the independent
content creator removed.
And by the way, also
they co-produce a
show YouTube and Vox
along with there's licensing
agreements with Netflix.
So for me, it was
really important.
And I think this resonated
with people as opposed
to individuals,
it was a David versus Goliath
where it's like, look
it's easy to say,
"Hey we have a big
following and a big show
"but we've built
this over years."
And NBC universal Vox is
trying to take that away
because they were
late to the party.
They wanted to keep
everything off of YouTube.
We were there when
they were copyright
claiming everything and not
putting anything on YouTube.
And then they wanted to
compete and not to listen,
I hate to do this with Fox news
but I was at Fox news for
four and a half years.
My own interviews that
I would do on Fox news.
At this point, I may be at
50,000 subscribers on YouTube
were removed when I would ask,
"Hey can I upload
them" and said, "Sure."
And they said, you know what?
"We actually don't want
these things going on YouTube
"because we don't think
it has a longevity."
And now of course you see,
it's one of the very
few conservative outlets
that's consistently
featured on YouTube
because they have
that buying power.
And they're trying
to play catch up.
This is really
about legacy media
being behind the eight ball
and making up for
it with dollars
and what I would like to see
this doesn't relate
to our legal case,
but this relates
to the ecosystem.
Look, YouTube will
never be Netflix.
And if they want to understand
their business model
and how they survive, it's not
by letting legacy media try
and corporatize YouTube.
It's by focusing on
and supporting their
content creators.
But all of these, Turner
NBC universal, Disney ABC
there's really about
five companies.
They will do anything they
can to remove competition.
What's Brian Stelter
gonna do compete with you.
Compete with me honest.
I still want to know what
that guy did to get a show.
Chris Cuomo might get
his brothers governor
good-looking guy
Brian Stelter is untalented,
unattractive and uninformed.
And he gets a show
with no experience.
Well what's he gonna
that's why that guy
more aggressively than
any other on-air host
lobbies to have people removed
and D platform than
a regular basis.
It's because they're
afraid of competition.
- So do you think
you could ever get
to the point of popularity,
numbers, monetization
whatever you wanna call it,
that you would just be like,
All right, I don't wanna
do the legal route anymore
or we're not getting anywhere
or it's a strain and stress
and everything else, and
I'm just gonna be free.
Meaning I'll be on the blaze
or whatever else there might be.
And just not deal
with this nonsense.
- I could probably do that, now,
in the sense that if I just,
we were just talking
about surviving
and keeping my people employed
I could probably do that now
because we have a lot
of people who support us
and who joined up with my club.
But we've always said that
we want to make sure that,
the supported content is
what allows the free content.
For me my goal is always to have
as many people out
there who at least are
whether or not they're
conservative free
speech advocates.
For me, I'm a simple guy.
I'm pretty right wing but first
amendment, second amendment,
especially coming from a
country that has neither Canada
are pretty important to
me, to give you an analogy.
And I've always talked
about this where I'm,
big into firearms, but
I'm not a collector.
I'm not a Maven.
What I would rather see
out, there are 50 people
with one firearm than
one person with 50.
I want more people
comfortable around firearms.
Those who've taken basic
firearms safety courses
who understand how firearms
work, because once that happens,
you can no longer
have Joe Biden go up
and say an AR 14
is a machine gun.
First off human AR 15, not 14,
and it's not a machine gun.
It's a semiautomatic, just
like any other handgun.
So for me, it's really
important to be on YouTube
and be on Facebook and be on
Twitter to reach new people
and to create new
free speech advocates
and new firearm owners,
new conservatives
people who will understand
what this country
was founded on and continue
those values forward.
So could I leave, take
my ball and go home
and make enough to
live comfortably
with the people who
will support us probably
but we're not going
to be reaching any
new hearts and minds.
So for as long as I can
be on those platforms
and even if I'm just
a thorn in their side
that's a good
thing that tells me
that we're reaching
a lot of folks.
- Yeah, I'm with you,
Bill what about just the
culture of fear around lawyers?
I sort of hit on this earlier,
but just when you're
talking to your colleagues
or other people at your firm,
or just when you're
talking to Crowder's fans,
I mean, you gotta
be somewhat afraid
that they're gonna bust
into all your emails
and whatever else we
can think they can do.
And probably what's
worst is the stuff
that we can't
imagine they can do.
- There's certainly
a concern about that.
I do get a lot of
communications from folks.
I think the ones that
are the most damning
of where we've come as a
culture is when I get emails
from law schools across the
country, from law students.
And I get Instagram messages
and tweets and sometimes calls.
And they're just like, wow, I
can't say anything about this.
I can't remotely show
that I'm conservative.
There are few that
are willing to do it
and they pay the price for it.
I'm just gonna get my degree
work quietly and move along.
The number of folks who, I
show up and they go, Oh wow.
They sent me an email.
I go, I didn't even realize
that you were conservative.
You just never came up
in committee meetings
or organization meetings or
at a bar function or whatnot.
And because of that
culture of fear
and it to a certain extent,
you just have to say, it's okay
I'm gonna accept whatever
might come down that pipe
and deal with it.
Because when you're dealing
with these companies
that's certainly gonna happen.
Fortunately for me
we've got a broad base
of different clients
and different folks
who were supportive
and really just
say, great lawyers.
I don't care, let's hire
them, let's go get it done.
I think the folks like Steven
have to really step
out on a limb and have
along with other folks who
are even willing to talk
about these types of things,
knowing that all of the
strings are controlled
out of Menlo park and Palo Alto.
- And you know what on
that note, for example,
Gina Carano I can say this
now because it's public.
I've known this for a very
long time about Gina Carano.
Gina Carano has followed me.
We've invited Gina
Carano on the show
and she has watched the show.
I can't do it.
So now I think we'll
probably have in the show.
And by the way, she decided to
appear and Ben Shapiro show.
But one thing Ben
Shapiro can't claim
is an actual teenage
crush on Gina Carano
was a Brown belt in jiu-jitsu.
People know I come
by it honestly.
And I used to watch every
single Gina Carano fight
including her getting
manhandled by Cyborg
who tested positive
for steroids,
where effectively Gina
Carano was fighting a man
named Fallon Fox, but
I'd agree with that.
- Wait, hold on.
You're saying Ben Shapiro
is not a Brown belt
in jiu-jitsu when he was a kid?
- I'm saying Ben Shapiro
didn't know Gina Carano
until this happened unless
he's a star Wars nerd.
I followed Gina Carano when
she was fighting in the field
but I can tell you right
now, off the top of my head
I could give you another eight
to 10 Gina Carano, actually.
And some other people, including
people in the sport of MMA
including people who
would be current top 10
paid in Hollywood, who
would never come out.
And I would never out them.
They're still out there,
but I can tell you Gina
Carano was one of them.
And I certainly hope
that we have on the show
but that's so sad to me because
the thing about Gina Corana
I think this was a bigger
story than people even realize,
because yeah, you
have a lot of people
who've been in the platformed,
but there are a lot of
sort of conservatives
who guilty, abrasive and
they're easier to hate.
I think when people actually
tune into what we do
they understand that
the people sort of go,
Oh this is actually basic pitch.
Conservatism is the heart in
this is really not
malicious at all.
But Gina Carano was the
first example of someone
who was not really outwardly
political and nothing.
She said in any capacity could
be interpreted as malicious.
There was no malice to any
of it, as a matter of fact.
And I think that generally
speaking Holocaust
or Hitler comparisons
are ill-advised.
I think she was as thoughtful
and as tactful with that post
as one could be, because
she wasn't saying it's
like being a Jew, being a
conservative in Hollywood
which we'll show you saying is
it started by having
your neighbors
snitch on their neighbors.
And I think that's
the important thing
people use this term
sort of cancel culture,
and it didn't exist.
By the way I pitched the
book for change my mind,
I've talked about this many
times to conservative publishers
and there was no cancel culture.
So I had these, but
I described SJWs.
I described leftist activist
and I described people who
are sort of liberal by default
and sort of what ended up
becoming the alt-right.
But I just had
different words for it.
And every single
publisher turned it down
and said this book is silly.
No one will ever wanna
do a change by mind book.
But what's so crazy about
this, I don't wanna say crazy.
What really makes me sad
is when people say good,
good for Gina Carano
being removed.
And you look at the content
of what it is that she
said, that's people saying,
good I hope you never
have the ability
to provide for
your family again,
this is desensitizing people.
This could easily be
desensitizing people
towards something
much more sinister.
Not saying it is,
not saying as part of
some conspiracy plan, but
when people are saying
cancel that person,
they're supporting it.
They're supporting the ending
of people's livelihoods
which by the way is
exactly what they're doing
with COVID lockdowns and
businesses and saying,
how much is your life worth?
Hold on a second, you're
talking about a 0.17%
whatever it is death rate,
which by the way
is the exact number
that those California
doctors were banned
for communicating on
Facebook and YouTube.
Because at that point it was
the Imperial college of London
saying it was a two to 4%
death rate hold on a second.
You're saying how
much is my life worth?
Because we have
60% of businesses
now that are there'll
be open in April.
That won't be open in September.
How much is a livelihood
worth people right now
are so quick to go along with
removing someone's ability
to provide for their
family forever.
And if you get people
okay with that,
I don't think it's that
much of a leap to say that
you get desensitized
to dehumanizing
people to any degree.
- Yeah, I actually, I was away
when the whole Gina Carano
thing happened last week.
So I didn't address
it on the show
but I'm completely with you
just for the record crowd.
Or like there was nothing
remotely anti-Semitic
or anti-Jewish or anything
like that, that she said
she was actually making a
pretty thoughtful point.
And the irony of course
is the people that were
trying to destroy her.
They call everybody Nazis
which would be a far worse
cultural appropriation
or labeling than anything
she did, Bill go ahead.
- There's a little bit
of a frog in hot water.
The whole analogy.
If you throw the ho the frog
into hot water, he'll jump out.
But if you just turn heat
up, you desensitize the frog,
he'll stay in there
and boil to death.
And that's what we're
looking at right now.
A couple episodes, you
talked about a CNN reporter
who was able to say, "Oh, well
under the first amendment,
"you can't lie."
And you eviscerate,
you had great argument
about why that was wrong, but
you made a really good point.
You actually made two points,
one expressly, one implicitly,
you said, "She's wrong,
"we should let her
know that she's wrong."
Now I'm not saying cancel
or anything like that.
And that's the way you engage
in a respectful communication.
You can be harsh and
critical about someone
saying something incorrect
especially a legal correspondent
on a national news network.
But you can also say
that doesn't mean
we're erasing her
from her business
from her livelihood
or anything like that.
You made that so consciously
it's built into your
value system to say
I'm not gonna engage
in cancel culture,
but calling people out
is the important part.
And that's part of what the
important part of staying
on YouTube and being able
to call these platforms out
about what they're doing
and how they've converted
themselves into publishers
how they've converted
themselves into being editors
and content creators themselves
and gone all the way around
to 30 is to be able to say,
Hey we have other voices
and people want to
hear those other voices
just play by the rules.
- And when they say these rules
are being enforced equally,
they say, regardless
of political viewpoint,
that's a really clever thing.
They just did this
recently with a
to use a nonpolitical
example Pewdie pie
and what's that kid's
channel, I don't know.
In other words, it was a
selective enforcement of satire.
It was a distrac on YouTube
aimed at a kid's channel.
And they said, we believe that
this violates our guidelines.
When they say these
are applied equally
regardless of point of view,
well, hold on a second.
When you say that these
are applied equally,
and by the way if you say
that you believe people can't
change their biological sex
which is a medical fact we're
not talking about gender here
gender theory, Judith
Butler, Simone de Beauvoir.
They say, "Well, that's a
violation of a guidelines."
There is no way to
apply that equally
because you've eliminated anyone
who has an opinion
different from yours.
That's the point, for example
we had one video on YouTube
where I was doing
to change my mind.
And there was a male
to female trans person
very newly male to
female trans person,
by the way meaning like
that day, who assaulted me
and threw a homeless
man's lunchbox at me.
And then we did a play by play.
And we laughed at the way
this trans male to female
ran away in Z's high heels,
because it was funny.
And that was considered
more offensive
than stealing a
homeless man's lunchbox
and throwing it at me.
And by the way, I
don't even think
I was talking about
genders at that point.
I think I was talking
about male privilege.
So this is to say that
that's applied equally.
There's no way to
apply that equally.
The deck is stacked from
the get-go with those rules.
And then you go a step
further where with Facebook
they haven't even clarified
what the rules are
or what the violation is.
So we know that based on the
publicly available guidelines
with companies like YouTube,
and I would say they do a
better job than Facebook
to give them credit there.
Then it's not really
applied equally.
And then when you don't
have them publicly available
and they don't give
any rationalization
for removing content, look
maybe you think you're
maybe you're out there and you
think that Facebook is right.
How do you know?
We don't know if we
think they're right.
We can't know where
the notification is.
- Right, so that gets
to my point earlier
about how social justice,
critical race theory,
all of these bad ideas
that have now infected
all of these companies,
they're in direct combat
or conflict with reality.
So when you say that there
are biological differences
between men and women, which
everyone knows to be true
every biologist knows
that to be true,
but that doesn't fit
in with the SJW thing
that these companies
have now put into
their terms of service.
They've put into the way
they behave with their boards
and everywhere else,
it's almost like this is a
totally intractable problem
because their reality
actually is different
than the reality that we've
known for thousands of years.
- You know, what's funny.
That was actually, I
will say this with the
in the people said,
well why do you focus on
the transition so much?
Well, I will say this because
as a Christian conservative,
I believe when you
say that there is no
fundamental difference at all
between men and women that,
men and women are
completely interchangeable.
I think that's a real
problem for our civilization.
I think it's a real,
it's a real problem.
If we're not saying that,
Hey there are moms or dads,
there are boys there are girls
because you raise
them differently.
Not only that you
support them differently
as a community you find out
how to help them differently.
But I will say this, there
is something kind of funny.
We were talking
about this earlier
on my program this morning,
about how things
that you would say
would be considered toxically
masculine or patriarchal
or be considered anti-woman
unless it's trans.
So for example, you know,
the 50 year old man, who's
playing college basketball
in the girl's sleek
or Fallon Fox,
who lived as a man and
father children into his 30s.
And then, beat up women
identifying as a female.
When you read their
stories, what they say is
you know what, when I
came out to my teammates
you're six foot, 845
pounds, by the way, I think
I don't think they, I think
they deserve an Academy award.
If you think you were
coming out, but they said
"My teammates never knew this."
I was just reading
this today on air.
My teammates never
knew this because
my level of endurance,
strength, my lung capacity
I was the same as other women.
Well, hold on a second,
what are you implying there?
Or if you look at
a lot of the times
what a trans male to female is,
well, it's really
perpetuation of these
unrealistic beauty standards.
It's usually someone
dressing like a Barbie
with a blonde wig and
over the top makeup.
And usually they end up
getting breast implants.
These are things that
are thought of as
toxic masculine
stereotypes, until you say,
well I'm trans and
people didn't know
because I'm weaker, I'm
smaller, I'm slower.
I don't have the
same lung capacity
but look at my blonde
wig and makeup.
That's what a woman is.
It distills both sexes
to the stereotypes that
we're supposed to reject.
Only now we have to embrace
as a part of this very
very new by the way,
a sort of gender experiment.
And I think that that's
also really important
as it relates to the
speech guidelines online.
Because when you effectively
are saying that half
of the medical community are
not allowed to voice an opinion
that your rules are
being applied equally
then I just disagree as
to what equally means.
And then of course, we get
back to the idea of Facebook
where they don't
even say what it is.
We still have no, what
happened with the stream?
Where's it gone?
It's gone, just give the answer.
- And Dave, on
that point, I mean,
when you look at
the rules themselves
and the way they've been set out
even the very basic
statement of saying,
we won't allow
hate or harassment
based on race, religion,
political ideology,
and you say, okay.
So you're not allowed to make
fun of white male Christians.
Okay, got it.
All right, is that...
- Wait, do they say
political ideology?
I'd be shocked if
that ends in there.
- So they used to say
political ideology.
And then in 2016, they
actually gave statements
to the Senate saying "We
don't actually do it."
And that was the thing that
they trumpeted everywhere
because it wasn't in
their particular rules
but they were being
called out about it.
And they said, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no.
In case anyone is concerned,
we do not do that.
I mean, it's in the response
letter, it's in their articles.
Multiple spokesperson
said we do not do that.
And that is the thing that they
have advertised ever since.
And they even say it now you
have Mark Zuckerberg saying
"No, Senator, we do not engage
"in any kind of
ideological considerations.
"We do not suppress
conservatives."
And I'm not saying they suppress
every single conservative.
No, that's not a Hill
anyone needs to die on
it's a question about
individual voices
and what they're doing and
the rules as they have them.
But how do you
define these things?
They can't define them.
And yet at the end
of the creators
are the ones that are
abused because of...
- And by the way, this is
just as much for liberals
as it is for conservatives.
I mean, keep in mind,
look this is something
also to consider.
When people said Donald
Trump was anti press
he had the power
of the executive.
I was actually disappointed
that Donald Trump
didn't do more on section 230.
Didn't do anything to
actually get anybody.
Oh, he revoked some
people's press pass
because they asked some
dishonest questions
for a day and a
half, think about it.
I don't want, if there's
a Republican in power,
I want that potential tyranny,
regardless of who's
willing that power
to have some checks
and balances.
This is just as much
for future liberals
because I don't want them to
be removed from the platform
outside of criminality meaning
actually calling for violence
or physical harm to people.
These are things that we
have laws for these things.
This is just as
much for liberals
as it is for conservatives.
It's just really hard for
liberals right now to see that
because even though
Donald Trump was president
for four years and
even during that time,
they see themselves
as the ones in power,
because you have really
three to five companies
who are more powerful than
any national government
that has ever existed in
the world before today.
And that's Facebook, Twitter,
Alphabet, Apple, Amazon.
- So does that worry you
or does that push your
your libertarian
stuff to the end?
'Cause I mean, I agree
with you on that.
And it's like if you're
breaking the laws
of the United States then
you've got a bigger problem
than the platforms
because then the government
is gonna go after you.
So that should clean
up most of that.
But, you hear, there were all
these conservatives saying,
Oh Trump had to do sign
and now I still hear
some of them saying it, but
it's like, wait a minute.
I thought you hate Biden.
So now you want the
government involved
even though it's not
your guy anymore.
Like it sort of just basically
flipped everybody's beliefs.
On top of themselves.
- My position has always
been very consistent.
Whereas I just want
the first step is them
deciding I want them to
publicly declare their platform
if they want to be treated
as such or a publisher
because they're kinda benefiting
from both sets of
rules right now.
And you have to pick one.
Either you are liable
for the kind of content
on your platform.
In which case you
can take these four
you can take these actions,
which they take, which
act beyond the law.
And in some cases, by the
way don't even follow the law
because there's a
different set of online law
to give me an idea here.
We had a, for a long time
in this country, okay.
An idea of what
investigative journalism was,
that no longer exists.
It no longer exists because
first off we have single
party consent laws.
YouTube and Facebook don't
necessarily follow those laws.
So you can say, okay
we're finding someone who's
a corrupt member of Congress
or, a Senator running for
president, for example.
And we're in a single party
consent state, which means that
legally you have the right
to record this conversation.
And I catch them in an act
that is deliberately harmful.
That is deliberately
manipulative,
something like that.
I mean, for example, the
access Hollywood tape
you can follow all these
laws and it can be removed
because YouTube
says they want to,
it can be removed as
we've seen on the same day
from YouTube, Facebook, Twitter
even though you follow
the laws and then
if you've broken the laws,
it can be allowed to stay up.
That is a very,
very scary thing.
We've had this happen where
we've interviewed people
on the street, right where we've
and we were already in
single party consent States
where we had the right
to interview people
but had them sign release forms
to be on air with
these questions.
And then you YouTube actually,
this someone said this was
a violation of privacy.
So this was a public protest.
Well, there's no reasonable
expectation of privacy.
And by the way, we have them
if we want us to
send you the form.
We have them on camera
confirming and consenting.
They say, it doesn't
matter because now the rule
is if anyone ever
regrets being on camera
we're going to remove it.
Well, how wonderful that
would have been for Nixon,
how wonderful for Anthony Wiener
investigative journalism
doesn't exist anymore.
And that is scary
because these people can
effectively create the laws
and that determines what
you can and can't see.
And it determines who and who
is never held accountable.
- Yeah Bill, is there
anything you can do
or look into on the moving
goalposts portion of that?
So for example, after 2016
basically every
lefty YouTube channel
ran for four years
and not just them, CNN
everybody ran with,
Russian collusion.
He's a fake president.
Hillary Clinton said, he's
illegitimate the whole thing
but you guys know that if we
were to even discuss anything
about this last election,
that both of us could
you could probably get booted
being my guest right now.
Is there anything you
can look into on that?
- Well, it's certainly something
that we're going to be
looking at very closely
because of the fact that
this case involves fraud.
It's a question of are
you taking policies
and enforcing them one way
depending on the speaker
versus the other.
Now folks on the left will say
that's exactly what
you're supposed to do.
If someone who has one
skin color says something
and someone who has a different
you have to view them as very
and completely different.
That's actually a
fundamental value
of certain groups in the
country who tend to be
lobbying these platforms
and publishers about
how they're actually
engaging in their business.
But what we're saying
is no, your rules say
you will not treat the
speaker differently
based on who the speaker
is or their characteristic.
And that's the rule that
we're trying to say.
So of course, we're going
to be looking at saying,
"Well why did you decide to
let this content stay up?"
But yet you took this
other content down
because you said that it
was hateful or harassing
or going against a
certain race or religion
or whatever it may be.
Or you thought that it
was not speaking exactly
how you should speak about COVID
or wasn't parroting the
current version this week
about what the WHO is saying
the rules are on
masks or vaccines.
And you go and you find
those hypocritical examples.
Every one of those is
absolutely relevant
to not only our lawsuit,
but it's very relevant
to all of the state governors
and attorney generals who are
going after Google, Facebook
and the other
platforms is based on
their anti-competitive
antitrust lawsuits
that are going out
there right now.
- Bill, let me ask
you something else
before I let Steven jump
back in on the legal side.
I mean, I'm a firm
believer at this point,
I'm in crazy LA
California, right now.
We don't know for how
much longer, but at least
as we're recording this,
that lawsuits are gonna be what,
what actually turns
this country around
which I hate to say, although
it probably sounds
good as a lawyer
that it will ultimately be suing
Gavin Newsom, will be suing
Andrew Cuomo and getting all
of the stuff on discovery
that will show that there was
no science behind lockdowns
and the arbitrary
decisions they made.
And it was much more about
politics than everything else.
Do you see that as the way
that we get out of this
this endless half state
of lockdown that we're in?
- It's going to be that way.
It's going to be your
investigations of Cuomo.
It's going to be
your investigations
in a variety of
different States.
It's looking into what
was said publicly.
And this cuts both ways.
I mean, this is really
important to say
we're talking about
universal principles here
that cut across all
ideologies being pro-business
but being anti-fraud
requiring businesses
to give adequate disclosures.
When you're a politician
saying the truth
based on the information you
have, maybe you're mistaken.
People get mistakes
all the time.
Governments make
mistakes all the time.
- I didn't mean to say the
N word he are clear as day
but he did it.
- And you own up
to those mistakes?
And then you live
with the consequences.
Fortunately, we do live
in a country that says
that we will allow
this to happen.
However, there is a dangerous
precedent being set right now.
And you kinda talked
about it earlier
which is a cancel culture
as it relates to
even the legal field.
Whether or not certain lawyers
or law firms should
not be allowed to do it
because of who they voted for
or the positions
that they espoused.
And again, we're not talking
about crazy policies.
We already have laws in place.
We already have
disciplinary rules in place
that have worked for decades
and decades and decades.
But to now say,
well, wait a minute
I don't really like
their voting record.
I don't really like the policies
that they're talking about.
So now they can't
even bring a lawsuit.
Now they can't even
show up in court
who is going to represent the
individuals who are saying,
wait a minute these companies
need to do something different.
Look, we're we have no
qualms about the fact
that there's go]nna
be an uphill battle
between the California
federal court
a California based
court of appeals
and eventually having to
get to the Supreme court.
We know that that's
going to be the case.
We know that the
misinterpretation of section 230
which is titled good Samaritan
it says you have to
have a good faith basis
for removing the content
in order to have liability
not a complete blanket of
saying, well, we woke up today
and we decided to just
cancel this entire page.
That's how it's being
interpreted right now.
And we know that
this is the only way
that it's going to happen.
I still have full
confidence in exercising
the legal remedies that
we have in this system
if for some reason, and
I'm guessing right now
it's not going to happen.
That the legislature
doesn't get something
Congress doesn't get
something done to change it.
Whether it's Biden,
whether it's Trump
whether it's the
candidate in 2024
whether it's any
candidate in any Congress
whether it's center of the house
that everyone needs to come down
with these universal
values of saying
that businesses need
to be held liable when
their violin laws not
have and protection
like 230 currently
being interpreted
and simply can't
engage in rampant
ongoing fraud of every person
who's on these platform.
- And I was just one of those.
Those came in one of
those boots, those shoes?
- I don't know stamp leathers.
- He's wearing
some spiffy shoes.
Sorry, Dave, I got
distracted by his shoes.
I have, I have two
points to make.
I want you to go first.
- Well, I was gonna say that
as you were laying
that out, though,
it reminds me of years ago when
all of the nonsense started
with YouTube very early on
and I finally got a contact.
I'm sure Crowder you
remember at first
when you finally get a
human being there somehow
when I get somebody and you
finally get an email address
and somebody actually said
whoever the YouTube
partner manager was
whatever you wanna
call them said
because I kept saying,
"Hey, I'm getting
these emails every day.
"And hundreds of
tweets every day
"and people are being
unsubscribed from my channel."
So they said in an email,
I still have the email.
They said, "Oh, well, after
weeks we looked into it
"and there is a
bug on your channel
and we're gonna see
what we can do."
Now then of course I don't hear
from them for a month or two
finally, right back.
And then I got a form letter
email saying "This person
"no longer works in
this department."
And you can do
everything through the,
just like the manual submission
thing and that was it.
So Bill, that gets
to your point about,
how they decide,
okay, you got a human.
Now you got a robot
Crowder, take it away.
Bring us home here, Crowder
- I was gonna sas a
couple of things here.
First of all, I understand
your point as a libertarian.
I have a little bit of a
different point of view
on lawsuits.
I do think that we're an
overly litigious country
but I think there's
a difference between
being an actual
ambulance chaser.
Who's cheating on your
wife on her death bed
with a pregnant woman
like John Edwards.
Versus did I just say, I just
found this out yesterday.
My uncle Emo who is largely
based on a French Canadian.
He was we just, I just found
out yesterday that he has
pretty advanced kidney cancer.
He's going to have
to have it removed
but he's had it since July.
Do you know why
they didn't tell him
his papers fell
between the desk?
This is Quebec
socialized healthcare.
Now tell me that's not a lawsuit
that's legitimate at that point,
you're talking about seven
months of cancer advancing
because you dropped the
papers between the desk.
That's what happened.
There is really no
recourse in Canada.
And of course the
quality of care is
nowhere near as it is here.
So his, the actual mortality
rates are higher to begin with.
So I do think that, lawsuits
are a form of
checks and balances
that are important
in this country.
I also think it's important
for people to understand,
the burden...
- Wait, where was our
disagreement on that though?
'Cause I'm with you on that.
- No, I know you were
saying as a libertarian,
you'd hate to say that, the
solutions are with lawsuits.
I know we were coming
from, because I think that,
we probably support
things like tort reform.
And I think that there
are a lot of lawsuits out.
There were, the system is abused
but I do think
coming from Canada,
where really there there are
often very few legal recourses
as it relates to business
that I actually see that
as a wonderful thing.
When applied appropriately
here in the United States
I think something
else that's important.
You talked about the
election as far as I know,
these are YouTube.
Not as far as I know
I've read them in depth.
YouTube guidelines are, you
can talk about voter fraud.
Well, thank God because
otherwise Elizabeth Warren
and Amy Klobuchar will
be banned from YouTube.
So what Jimmy Carter, you
can say that there's even
been voter fraud
to large levels.
What you can't,
what you can not say
is that it in any way affected
the outcome of this election
to give you an idea as to the
burden of proof requirement
that is put on
conservatives at this point,
because there've
been a lot of people
who've been banned simply for
talking about the election.
I have gone on air and, and
half-ish, and Bill knows this.
I have only made
claims about things
that I've actually gone
through voter rolls.
When I say that
there are addresses
in this election, for example,
in Nevada and Michigan
from people who
don't actually exist
or addresses that weren't there.
I actually had to send
my staff or myself
go there and take
pictures at the empty lot.
Under an overpass.
These are addresses
where people voted from
or on a construction
site with a picture
of today's newspaper and
we'll have a video coming out.
So when I say, I make these
claims under penalty of perjury
what does the New York
times have to say?
What do the young Turks
have say, what is it?
They just say, there is no
evidence of voter fraud, really?
What due diligence
have you done?
And that's the issue
right there it's
when you require me
to fly on my own dime
or send an intern on my own
dime to go take pictures
with today's newspaper, just
so that I can make a claim
that we know is verifiably true.
And there is no requirement
for research sources
due diligence on
any of the leftist.
You show me any of these
programs at ABC, NBC, CBS, MSNBC
any of the online
ones like young trucks
who list all of their sources.
As we do any day with
every single show,
you may disagree with me
every now and then you may say,
you know what that's
not the best source.
That's actually not the best
study that comes from pub med.
I have a more effective
meta analysis, sure.
But it's not even asked of
the left to do that work.
That's not a level
playing field.
- Crowder I know everyone
knows where to find you,
we'll include the
links down below.
If, people wanna help you guys
or if they have any insider info
or their whistleblowers
or whatever else there is,
is there anywhere that
they can contact you,
Bill I'm sure you
want to hear from
all of my YouTube commenters,
all the stuff that they know?
- Whistleblowers contacts
chelsea_manning@louderwithcrowdm
and we have sorting through,
no actually you can
always join my club
lateralcutter.com/mudclub.
And people can obviously
watch us there on the blaze.
I think we have fight
like hell of a promo code.
People get $30 off where's
the best place for...
- So we have a lot of folks
who are coming in through
the life advice email
and
lifeadvice@lateralcrowder.com.
And look, this is an important
kind of perhaps final point,
which is the necessary evil
that it comes with lawyers.
If people were just
good to each other
if businesses didn't commit
fraud, you wouldn't need
the large amount of lawyers
that you have today.
And that's unfortunate that
we have to rely on that
because the government and
the Congress hasn't stepped in
to fix section 230 the
courts haven't done
what they needed to
do to interpret that
in the correct way.
And it is a thing that we
have to do, but ultimately,
one of the most important
things that is gonna change
is people who are
deciding to move
with their eyeballs and
ears to different platforms.
It's these other nascent
platforms that are growing
that ultimately folks are
gonna go, wait a minute.
Those shareholders we talked
about earlier are gonna go,
why is everyone leaving?
Why can't we just
be an open platform?
Why do we have policies
that no one understands it
that we enforced discriminately?
That's gonna maybe be
the thing that changes it
faster than a four year slog
to the Supreme court back down
and years and years of discovery
these companies have the
money to be able to do that.
But if the country wants to
go in the right direction
the consumers have
to do something
and the government
has to as well.
- I think it goes without saying
I'm in the fight with you guys.
So anything I can
do, let me know.
Bill Richmond, thanks for
being on the show and Crowder.
It was April, 2016, that's
four years and 10 months,
I'm thinking we'll do the next
one four years, eight months.
I felt like you
brought it today.
- That's fair enough,
that's fair enough.
I hate myself today.
(laughs)
- All right, thanks
guys good luck.
If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about comedy
instead of the nonstop yelling,
you get everywhere else
check out our comedy playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, check
out our full episode playlist.
They're both right over here
and to get notified
of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.